-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
you're doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
Well, there are just
15 days left in 2021,
and by my calculations, it
leaves two more years of 2020.
[ Laughter ]
When asked
by reporters yesterday
if his Build Back Better act
will pass Congress
by the end of the year,
President Biden said,
"It's gonna be close."
Buddy, it's December 16th.
It's already close.
[ Laughter ]
At this point,
even Amazon Prime's like,
"How's March?"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
and Vice President Kamala Harris
met with members
of the White House
Coronavirus Response Team today
to discuss the omicron variant,
which was pretty awkward,
considering it was right there
in the room with them.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know
it got such a good seat.
[ Laughter ]
According to new data,
an initial symptom
of the omicron
coronavirus variant
may be a scratchy throat.
Oh, man, then I wouldn't
get so close, Little Steven.
[ Laughter ]
And I want you all
to realize that I do know --
In back-to-back jokes, I went
"ahm-icron" and "oh-micron."
[ Laughter ]
Just trying
to cover all my bases.
[ Laughter ]
Hope you're all happy.
NASA announced this week
that its Parker Solar Probe
became the first spacecraft
in history to touch the sun.
And if you want to get some idea
of the intensity
of that kind of heat,
microwave a burrito.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration this
week reversed a Trump-era rule
allowing more powerful
shower heads.
Well, there goes
the divorced-aunt vote.
[ Laughter ]
I say "ont."
I get a lot of grief around here
for saying "ont."
Shoemaker, our producer,
always tells me it's "ant,"
and yesterday,
we had Marisa Tomei on the show,
and he told me,
'cause she's in "Spider-Man"
and she plays Aunt May, and
he's like, "It's not 'ont' May.
Like, don't embarrass yourself."
[ Laughter ]
"It's 'ant' May,
and you do that all the time."
And then he said,
"And even worse,
Paul Rudd is not 'ont'-Man."
[ Laughter ]
Which I guess I had been doing.
I didn't even realize.
[ Laughter ]
Former First Lady Melania Trump
announced today
that she will launch
a new NFT platform,
which is crazy 'cause I always
thought she was one.
[ Laughter ]
"Wait. I think
that NFT just blinked."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
experts are projecting that
"Paw Patrol" toys
will be a popular
children's Christmas gift
this year.
It's the gift that'll have
your nephew saying, "I'm 13!"
[ Laughter ]
"Do better, 'ont'-Man!"
And that was a monologue,
everybody.